qu'est-ce que tu achètes toi bah moi des
Nike
ça coûte cher
en moyenne ces petits anges reçoivent
130 francs par mois mais allez savoir
pourquoi il paraît qu'on donne moins aux
filles qu'au garçon
donc je disais que lui sa passion c'est
le scooter
pour mettre des accessoires dans les
cigarettes et sorties et toi c'est
pareil je crois que le scooter quoi déjà
c'est les dettes
tout à fait représentatif de la
génération Game Boy c'est ludique
logiciel qui passionne les garçons
d'aujourd'hui Laurent adore le basket
les jeux vidéo et les fringues de marque
bien évidemment pas le genre pantalon à
pince
de ne pas d'argent par semaine ou par
mois c'est quand tu as besoin
je lui demande je lui dis pourquoi et
elle a confiance en moi car c'est que je
vais lui redonner la monnaie toi tu
gardes jamais la monnaie
si on donne 10 francs et que ça coûte 8
francs tu rentres de francs
je lui rendais franc et si elle ne veut
pas me les donne
tu es un garçon
[Musique]
et tu connais des garçons qui sont moins
honnêtes que toi
dans sa tirelire 67 francs 50 pas de
quoi acheter la dernière console vidéo à
la mode
c'est la Playstation mais le prix
c'est combien
la console
c'est une console 60 bits ou 80 bits
c'est comment le niveau de jeu quoi la
vitesse de jeu
depuis le 1er jeu vidéo pong lancée par
Atari en 75 le virus s'est propagé fin
94 il y avait en France 7 millions de
consoles vidéos
ça touche absolument toutes les
catégories sociales sont discrimination
alors pourquoi c'est parce que c'est la
passion principal je crois que le gosse
qui est dans une famille et qui est pas
spécialement fortuné mais ça va être sa
priorité donc le cadeau de la grand-mère
le cadeau de l'attente etc l'argent qui
va recevoir pour son Noël pour son
anniversaire il va le mettre là-dedans
il va le mettre là-dedans en priorité en
plus je pense qu'il y a une question de
positionnement social il y a une
vingtaine d'années par exemple
positionnement social au lycée dans la
cour du lycée c'était par exemple la
musique c'était j'ai le dernier Beatles
ah tu as eu le dernier Dylan qui a été
voir les Stones en concert c'était comme
ça maintenant la culture le
positionnement social par rapport aux
copains c'est un tu as pas le dernier
version Street Fighter 2 ou tu as pas eu
la playstation ou la Saturne et là on
est déconsidérés et ça me fait penser
vraiment à des choses qui se trouvent
chez les adultes où on voit des familles
qui sont pas spécialement fortunés qui
vont se saigner prendre des des dettes
énormes des crédits énormes pour acheter
une belle bagnole pour se positionner
par rapport au collègues de bureau ou
aux voisins ou à la famille on peut pas
vivre dans le passé pour abandonner
[Musique]
deux attractions et un marchand de
ballon
le jeu favori Jules ne vend s'appelle
thème Park il s'agit de gérer un parc
d'attraction
s moi j'ai 9 francs par semaine et quand
j'aurai 10 ans citron et quand j'avais 8
ans j'avais 8 francs en fait tu me
manques d'un franc ouais
là là
le système n'est pas virtuel du carambar
au compact disc en passant par les
bandes dessinées japonaises tout un prix
de manga régulièrement tous les mois
j'en ai beaucoup là-dedans
et aussi tu entends les cassettes vidéo
on a une passion on essaye de d'y mettre
au mieux moi j'ai acheté tous les Akira
du 1 au 13 et ça fait à peu près 1000
balles les 13 fois un peu plus de 1000
balles
Akira ou Dragon Ball Z ce sont des héros
de manga traduisez bande dessinée
japonaise chez nous depuis quelques
temps ça se vend comme des petits pains
j'ai tracé
dans la tête aujourd'hui
6 ans et ce qu'on appelle un otaku un
fan de manga dans l'aventure il
engloutit tout son argent de poche 20
francs par semaine d'ailleurs pour des
images de Dragon Ball Z il irait jusqu'à
subtiliser un peu d'argent dans le sac
de sa mère
[Musique]
bibliothécaire ni coloriol à 46 ans et
vit seule avec ses deux enfants
partout par mois enfin c'est énorme et
vous lui dites il vaut mieux dépenser
ton argent autre chose vous laissez
libre pour dépenser
de les garder et c'est de les garder
pour acheter quelque chose un peu
plus mais il arrive pas ils font ça la
boutique de manga et bon toutes les
semaines il arrive pas
il a pas encore la notion de des choses
quoi pour lui
l'argent bah si j'en ai pas je vais à la
banque et puis et puis voilà je suis lui
expliquer que c'est mon salaire mais
il a l'impression qu'il peut tout avoir
qui peut que rien n'est impossible en
fait et
j'imagine que quand même ça va un petit
peu se je redoute l'adolescence
Dragon Ball Z 17 la passion c'est des
images de Dragon Ball Z pourquoi tu es
passionné par ce héros
parce que
j'aime bien la bagarre
on peut se les échanger et puis
des belles collections
ça passion c'est de écouter des disques
de la neige
moi je sais quand j'étais gamine j'avais
pas d'argent de poche mes parents
étaient profs tous les deux j'avais pas
le droit enfin j'avais pas et c'était
affreux parce qu'on me donnait des
bonbons et je pouvais pas les rendre
c'était et c'est quand même une fierté
de d'acheter quelque chose et de pouvoir
le rendre en fin de d'échanger et tout
ça et
je sais que quelquefois j'ai pris des
prélèvements n'importe où de ma mère
parce que c'était j'avais des bonbons à
rendre des choses comme ça c'était et
donc je voulais pas qu'on mes enfants la
même chose
disons que même si je suis sévèrement à
découvert je vais pas leur enlever leur
argent de poche
dépendant de plus en plus tard
consommateur de plus en plus tôt les
jeunes représentent un pouvoir
économique énorme 50% de la consommation
familiale et directement sous leur
influence traduit en chiffres ça
représente 500 milliards de francs
[Musique]
Goussainville banlieue nord ici on ne
roule pas sur l'or mais l'argent de
poche des enfants c'est sacré tu fais
des économies avec ton argent
après c'est bien ça après
ça coûte cher
au premier étage de notre immeuble
Yamina 16 ans comprend l'engouement de
ses copains pour les marques mais mais
quelques réserves
[Musique]
je sais pas moi des survêtements
Lacoste ou des choses comme ça c'est sûr
ça donne envie parce que c'est beau
c'est c'est prestigieux mais d'un autre
côté il y a la réalité de la vie on peut
pas toujours se permettre ce genre de
vêtements puis une fois de temps en
temps
les frères ou les parents ils peuvent
nous faire plaisir pour les
anniversaires pour les fêtes et il nous
offre quelque chose de mort voilà
[Musique]